in this video we are going to do a size
comparison video as well as a bit of a
description on the 25
longest c monsters in movies shows
and games of course there have been
quite a number of size comparison videos
on the largest of bigger sea monsters
but it's sometimes taken as height
or length or width all jumble up
together so here in this video we are
going to take them all by length
and showcase them in ascending order
from head to tail
the longest 25c monsters anyway if you
like our videos don't forget to
subscribe and smash that notification
bell
so here it goes number 25 the mosasaurus
from the jurassic world movies this apex
predator of the prehistoric deep
can feast on all manner of ocean life
their double hinged jaws open wide for
any prey
and they are not actually dinosaurs but
in fact marine reptiles
24 the meg hydrothermal vents down the
marianas trench
supposedly keeps its dark water secrets
and warm enough to support an ecosystem
teeming with life
one of these creatures in the ecosystem
is the megalodon shark
from the movie the meg 23 is precious
coming from ice age large even for a
whale precious was immense
and the beloved bed of granny who was
always seen throwing food into the ocean
so that precious might eat number 22
lagaya chris from monster hunter games
known as sea wyverns lagaycras are at
the top of the aquatic food chain
feared by sailors as the lords of the
seas they store electricity in their
spines
number 21 coral clawfish from star wars
it was a large
and nightmarish creature found in the
depths of naboo's seas
the koala clawfish had flat eel-like
bodies a bioluminescent tail
a crocodile-like head and a row of sharp
teeth and a set of mandibles
number 20 kraken from pirates of the
caribbean
the kraken was a legendary sea monster a
leviathan sent to prey on unwary ships
and marinas
a fearsome creature with tentacles
closely resembling a giant squid
number 19 cairdeas cadius is an elder
dragon introduced in monster hunter 3.
it has a beard a fur and two massive
horns which constantly grow
and eventually overtake the ice leaving
it blind
number 18 ebirah ebira was the primary
monster antagonist in ebrahar of the
deep
a huge crustacean mutated by nuclear
wastes produced by the red bamboo's
activities on lichi island
number 17 hydrous hydrous is the fan
name given to the 7th colossus
resembling an electric eel and a catfish
this colossus
swims in a giant murky lake in shadow of
the colossus game
number 16 gamera gamero was a gigantic
prehistoric species of tortoise who fed
on flames
and was reawakened by an accidental
atomic blast in the arctic between
american and soviet fighters dogfighting
over there number 15 the clover monster
in cloverfield it was conceived by the
film's creators as it being a newborn
and in cloverfield paradox 2018 a
similar but significantly larger
creature is seen
at the conclusion of the film number 14
the sea dragon leviathan
the sea dragon leviathan is a colossal
leviathan-class foreigner species it is
the largest aggressive creature of
subnautica
game the head of the sea dragon is stout
and reptilian in nature
number 13 zilla this is a giant mutant
iguana kaiju who first appeared in the
1998 tristar godzilla movie
and then re-adapted into the 2004 touhou
godzilla film godzilla final wars
it was sort of a godzilla you might say
number 12 characters characters was once
a beautiful giantess
the daughter of poseidon and gaia she
takes the form of a huge mouth that
swallows great amounts of water and
debris
three times a day creating multiple
massive whirlpools
number 11 cthulhu in the film underwater
cthulhu has been simplified to a very
large
organism and has no known supernatural
powers
sapiens or space origins nor does
the sight of him invoke madness and
insanity on people
number 10 the bewilder beast the
bewildered beast is a gigantic tidal
class dragon that first appeared in how
to train your dragon part 2
bewildered beasts are massive spiky
dragons with a pair of gigantic dust
like horns
number 9 kraken from clash of the titans
from the movie clash of the titans the
remake the creature possesses endurance
to match its strength in addition to
very long tentacles it was armed with
a gaping maw full of sharp teeth
number eight sandu aqua monster the sun
aqua monsters were enormous muscular
predators that could be found in the
oceans and lakes of naboo
although they could grow up to 200
meters long they were rarely seen
number seven the sea emperor leviathan
the sea emperor leviathan is a colossal
creature and
is the largest of the living leviathan's
class of fauna
found in the crater of the game
subnautica
it is sentient and also telephonic
number six raiju coming from pacific rim
an aquatic kaiju
raiju invokes a galapagos iguana and a
crocodile
in appearance and behavior all mixed
together broad shouldered raiju is
heavily armoured along its back and head
number five godzilla in the most of a
series of movies
godzilla is a type of giant prehistoric
amphibious reptile from the permian
period that fed on radiation on the
earth's surface
and then retreated deep underwater
following the permanent extinction
it is also a titan and a super species
number 4 slatin the largest and
strongest of all the known kaiju from
pacific rim
sladden is unrivaled by any of its
brethren in battle
the creature's high toxicity levels and
intelligence makes it the most lethal
kaiju
number three manda first appeared in
ishiro honda's 1963 film
sponsored by toho atragon manda is based
on a japanese dragon as
and is depicted as a giant sea dwelling
serpent which can survive on land as
well
number two leviathan from the mars
effect game the leviathans are an
ancient aquatic race that dominated the
galaxy in the time before the reapers
proud and aloof they regard themselves
as the galaxy's first
apex race and number one we have the
karathan
the karathan is a colossal sentient sea
creature and one of the most powerful
beings on earth she has guided the
trident of atlan in the hidden sea for
millennia and is the biggest
on this list and she also appeared in
the movie aquaman
and with this we come to the end of the
video but do check out this size
comparison video that we will
be putting right now so don't forget to
subscribe
um smash that notification bell and also
take a look at our other videos
take care fam
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh